Perhaps it is just a quirk of my nature
my slight excess of melanin but whatever
the reason I am completely immune to
white guilt I don't think white people
have anything to apologize for my offer
is this nothing and yet many people
disagree
including some of the loudest voices in
our culture so we will now do a tour of
white Guild hi hello hello Hello nice to
meet you hi I'm Nancy Nancy that's my
mom's name my dad named me after my
great aunt who was a slave okay I'm
sorry that's got to be a joke right I
think well think again this is pro this
could be an orientation session when you
go to a university this could be a
workplace diversity seminar in any case
though I'm not of the opinion that many
con conservatives are these days that we
ought to ignore history and we should
just judge every facet of society by
what is going on precisely at the
present day I don't think that's true
I'm kind of with the libs when they say
that his history has long-standing
effects I think that's true obviously
I'm a conservative I'm very concerned
with history and tradition but the
notion that one group of people uniquely
has suffered and therefore ought to
whine about it all the time is very
silly and not conducive to anyone's
flourishing what is conducive to your
flourishing is expressvpn which is the
group that has brought us this video
more from them in just a moment for now
let's continue to more white guilt yeah
I'm not a good white person learning to
understand that as I pursue anti-racism
it doesn't make me good it doesn't make
me the good white person is super
important because doing this work
doesn't make me a good white person it
makes me reasonable normal that I just
have the milk of hum kindness that I see
the suffering of 50 million other people
and that I care about it makes me simply
human it doesn't make me good good grave
he's very confused but it it comes from
a good place I think he's contradicting
himself right because he says most
people aren't doing this work most
people I'm I'm I'm one of the good ones
but I'm not one of the good ones but I'm
I'm trying to be aware in this extremely
racist world and just trying to be
normal and kind and good and anti-racist
that just makes you human even though
most humans aren't that way and I'm
special but I'm not special and I just
want to be
[Music]
good this is what happens when True
Religion collapses in your Society he's
following new kind of theology a new
kind of religion which which begins in
modernity and flowers out of liberalism
and now we'd call it wokeness or
anti-racism but the new religion is
really just a recapitulation and
synthesis of a lot of the heresies that
the old religion was able to do away
with 2,000 years ago the traditional
Christian way of becoming more good is
recognizing you're not good and begging
for God's grace and then opening
yourself up to cooperate with God's
grace and in so doing becoming
Sanctified but a works-based
religion is not going to save you you
are you are not capable of saving
yourself so nothing really new here it's
just a it's just a return of the old
false gods and and I feel bad for this
guy because he's at least starting from
a sincere and legitimate recognition of
his own insufficiency he just doesn't
know what to do with it so he drives
himself nuts just stop stop just stop
doing it you're going to drive me crazy
it's not luck it's privilege we're
privileged that people see us not a
color privilege that we don't get stared
at when we walk into the room privilege
that we don't get followed by security
when we go shopping or pulled over when
we're in the wrong neighborhood we're
privileged because Society was set up
for us and our silence keeps it in
place who set it up it was me
every society sets up its structures and
its norms and its habits for the people
in that Society is that so crazy I don't
know it seems like Common Sense what is
not common sense is the claim that they
make in the first part of that video
which is that when you're white people
don't see your skin color when you're
white they just see you for your
individuality but that's obviously not
true cuz the whole thesis of the video
is that they're all white and they're
all equally terrible you're both just
awful in modern societ the only group
that you are legally permitted to
discriminate against and socially
encouraged to insult and discriminate
against is white people that's the one
group white people it's not just that
the libs get it a little bit wrong that
they're perverting the truth they're
totally inverting the truth it's it's
just opposite day right now go to
expressvpn.com
YT do you ever read the fine print that
appears when you start browsing in that
incognito mode says your activity might
still be visible to your employer your
school or your internet service provider
to really stop people from seeing the
sites you visit you need to do what I do
and Trust expressvpn without expressvpn
every site you visit could be logged by
the administrator of that Network that
is still true even when you are in
incognito mode what's more your home ISP
can also see and record your browsing
data in the US they are legally allowed
to sell those data to advertisers
expressvpn is an app that encrypts all
of your network data and reroutes it
through a network of secure servers so
that your private online activity stays
just that private expressvpn works on
all your devices and it's super easy to
use you just click one button and you're
ready to go don't let strangers invade
your online privacy go to expressvpn.com
letter y letter T expressvpn.com YT to
get three extra months for free
expressvpn.com
YT I don't feel privileged because of
the color of my skin right now I because
of the color of my
hair during the last four years my eyes
have been opened and I am seriously
seriously disgusted ashamed to be around
so many people who share the same color
skin as I honestly I'm not a violent
person I've never been violent but since
dton an
Islander my temper has gone from zero to
a thousand real quick for the simple
fact racism is all around us whether you
want to admit it or not it is because I
see it but I'm disgusted to be white and
I'm actually ashamed to be white I can't
tell if she's joking because if you just
read what she was saying you you'd think
it might be sincere but she doesn't look
disgusted at herself it looks kind of
ironic and I can't tell if it's just an
elaborate bit especially because the
funniest part of the whole video is when
she says you know I've been just totally
normal and plastic my whole life but
ever since dating I don't know why she's
Irish now is she Irish I she's got that
red hair ever since dating a black man
now I just lose my temper all the time
I'm completely irrational I'm taking
away usts of passion you become
completely unreasonable if that's I
don't know that's why I think it's a bit
I think it's a bit but I I don't know
cuz the line between reality and satire
has
been
exploded we know he's God and he no
longer can be here
honor his legacy we're not ried God we
ask for forgiveness from our black
brothers and sisters for years and years
of racism of systematic racism I don't
think we need to worship black people
the is his problem if you don't want to
be a racist then you have to worship
black people if you don't you don't want
to be an anti-semite you have to worship
Jews if you don't want to be a homophobe
you have to worship homosexuals can't
you just be normal no
no the answer is no no no we're going to
end up either you know marching with
hoods on our heads with burning crosses
or we're going to go Bow Down and
Worship black people how just be normal
guys how about you just be normal it'll
be much more conducive to your
well-being all right everyone I really
want to thank all of the beautiful
perfect just could not improve in any
way races who watched this video the
Hispanics who are a little bit white
actually so let's put them to the side
the blacks the Asians the are there
other races I'm sure there are I I want
to thank all of you and to all of you
filthy disgusting white people good
riddens see you all next time I'm
green it'll do
fine it's
beautiful and I think it's what I want
to
[Music]
be